[Music]
heartaches get your heart hot takes on
ukraine baby let's go hello we're doing
it everyone's doing it sitting in there
300 gaming chairs trying to filter
information from across the world to get
some
special insight on an event they know
nothing about
you gotta have a take
here's a take for you i don't gotta take
i know nothing about this i don't know
anything about geopolitics
i don't know nothing about whether putin
is a rational actor
and i've spent invasion month not
learning a single thing about it so when
it was suggested
that we do a ukraine episode i vetoed it
because the only war that matters of
course
is the culture war
but then it was suggested that we cover
the
mystical dark philosophical entity
looming in the background of the ukraine
invasion
and now that makes for an episode yeah
i mean luckily we're bringing in some
more interesting stuff i think but uh
but yeah the debate around ukraine was
kind of funny to see people uh like
wanna adopt these different like causal
narratives about like why russia invaded
ukraine
and i always i don't know as someone
who's in a political science department
and you know is around people who study
international relations
um it was just interesting to see people
all of a sudden like adopt like ir
realist perspectives to say that oh like
you know because of nato expansionism
and all this stuff and
and and people saying things like oh
nato expansion caused
and it's like any time people talk about
causal links i i mean political science
is a dismal science like there's no
there's no
there is there is no like a scription of
like a definitive causal connection
there are many compounding factors and
if you talk to any honest political
scientist they'll tell you that but
there's just a lot of a lot of
confidence
uh about like what caused what and and
it's it was just funny to me to to see
people make definitive statements about
something that ultimately it is the
nature of such social political
phenomena i don't really think it's
possible to make a definitive causal
statement so
indeed indeed and of course there is an
army
of armchair experts i guess we're
sitting with the choir today we've got
our armchair psychologists telling us
whether or not putin is sane
what he expected to come from this how
his career as a spy informs his
decision-making processes
we have armchair generals predicting the
next move of russian forces we have
armchair insurrectionists telling
ukrainians who probably have better
things to do let's be honest
how to make anti-tank mines out of old
toasters or whatever and now you have us
your armchair intellectuals
who are about to tell you why this
really happened it's because
philosophy it's because hegel is bad
that's right and then we and you also
get and you also get the delightful
tankies who who are coming out and being
apologists for putin ah yes the tankies
defending that great communist leader
yeah the great communist the great
communist putin um it's so funny to you
to see people uh like the edgelords have
like little i mean first of all there's
we were just before we started recording
talking about zombies we've got like the
zombies with the ukraine flag in their
twitter bio and then we've got the
edgelords with the russian flag and the
[ __ ] twitter by us
yeah i guess you could say
you know that
it's multi-causal this
this isn't a single cause incident
that's that's the problem right
everybody wants to simplify it to a
single cause but you know remember back
to learning about world war one right
the uh black hand assassinating the
archduke was okay the spark that lit the
powder keg right and then the powder keg
was all of these different geopolitical
and historical arrangements that emerged
and the history is extremely complicated
and like basically you know you know
unless you're gonna do the work then
just shut the [ __ ] up and you know enjoy
the goddamn ride and don't pick sides
and treat this like it's a team sport
okay so so this is us shutting the [ __ ]
up yeah this is
and just to contradict exactly what i
just said let's go
episode i saw a meme the other day where
somebody was like whatever previous
geopolitical beliefs you happen to have
the war in ukraine vindicates them and
that's more or less been the response
that i've seen and it's kind of annoying
but i typically just want i've even had
students come up to me uh at the end of
a class on mediation um
alternative dispute mechanisms in canada
uh being like can you give me your
thoughts on the war on ukraine and i'm
like i don't know what you got from me
talking about how mediation works in the
province of ontario but sure why the
[ __ ] not i mean there's a real hunger
for commentary on this and i can kind of
understand why a lot of people
don't really know that much about
eastern europe or the geopolitics around
there so i guess they're just turning to
anyone who seems to have some kind of
expertise in something for resources on
that front so we have a a major conflict
or i don't i don't even know if it's a
major conflict there's conflicting
reports
and we did uh if you remember a few
months ago an episode on hyper real war
and that was
go for as the first
live news broadcast war and what do you
guys think about this this seems like
the first uh
social media
war in the same sense i don't think it's
a war i heard it's a special military
operation
yeah i heard i got that from right from
the top it's a denotification effort
he's just getting rid of a few nazis and
a bad problem
is always about information and
disinformation and
trying to follow this from the outside i
think is
totally futile there's 5 000 dead no
there's 10 thousand dead all the nazi
they're denotifying no we're denotifying
them no they're the nazis they they're
the nazis so
and then everyone just decides to take a
side you know i hashtag stand with
ukraine i mean i think there's two
aspects to the gulf war didn't happen
statement that beaudrilliard makes like
one it was yeah that the first media
mediated television mediated war so it's
it's pure spectacle
in other words all the the images aren't
you know some explaining some reality
that the images are pointing to all of
the press and coverage is part of it
okay and then the other point is you
know like a war isn't when one extremely
overpowered side with a mass amount of
technology comes in and just obliterates
the other side that's not a war that's a
slaughter but that's kind of splitting
hairs right because we see you know when
two sides are fighting there's a war but
i'm sure there are certain you know if
we want to get more specific about what
a war is you need two relatively equal
armies fighting and that's
not what has happened for a long time
there hasn't been two equal armies
fighting there's been the united states
and their allies which are
op as [ __ ] and then there's everyone
else who gets in their way but now china
russia and other places are able to
challenge that hegemony
i have someone
i have some a different take uh so my
first take on this is i think that in
some respects this affirms brochure's
intuitions about the chinese nature of
warfare even better than the gulf war
does i was just thinking the other day
that if there was ever a war where you
would want an actor
being your president this is the one
because lenski has done a fantastic job
of literally playing the heroic
ukrainian uh
standing against you know the invading
russian hordes and he's solicited
worldwide sympathy because he's played
into that role so effectively and in
case in case people like don't know like
zielinski was an actor in ukraine and he
was literally in a movie or i think it
was a show where he played
a school teacher
who then decides to run for president on
an anti-corruption campaign
and then in real life that actor ran on
an anti-corruption campaign and won with
the exact same party name as the name
that was used in the show yeah exactly
it was literally it's literally like
some scenario where
harrison ford plays the u.s president
the air force in air force one and then
decides like i'm actually going to run
for the president's plane but then all
of a sudden he's in the same scenario
and he actually does like a pretty good
job of it and you're like oh wow we made
the right choice on the other hand i do
think that this is
also a real war and the sense that for
instance the gulf war wasn't for exactly
the reasons that eric gave which is that
an extraordinarily one-sided conflict
can't really be described as a war in
the conventional sense because it does
seem like the ukrainians are actually
doing a fairly good job of repelling uh
the russian advance at tremendous cost
international support with having
international support everyone's sending
them weapons
which is really interesting so
yeah it's more of a two-sided conflict
than i think any of us expected right
well one of the narratives um that was
going on which is actually related to
the philosopher we're gonna talk about a
little bit later um and kind of like
russian nationalism
one of the narratives that i was saying
online was okay putin has been spending
all this time kind of
watching the west you know in in in
block in like air quotes the west you
know europe uh north america like canada
the united states etc
have been have never been more divided
internally right so and then of course
people allege that putin has been you
know running this disinformation
campaign you know the trump election all
this stuff just we all online with troll
troll farms you know trying to divide
and it's true i feel like
in a way right before he invaded ukraine
we were we were arguing over trucker
protests and vaccine mandates you know
internally extremely divided and i would
say in some ways identityless and
purposelessness
was kind of rampant and i think maybe
putin thought okay this is the perfect
time because they can't even agree on
simple things internally so now i'll
attack ukraine and they won't do [ __ ]
nothing's gonna happen
and i would say that it seems like if
that was a strategy it seems to me that
it's kind of backfiring because i would
say you know we haven't really seen
this much unity between uh sort of like
western countries
since probably like world war ii i mean
even more so in some sense because even
neutral countries like sweden and
switzerland
switzerland hasn't taken a side on on a
geopolitical conflict since the
napoleonic wars and they're sending
weapons to ukraine
and i want to point out this has even
surprised me uh because some of the
countries that seemed on the fence about
these issues like poland or hungary uh
have now kind of firmly or some of the
baltic states as well kind of firmly
sided uh with the west star with nato
however you want to connote it uh when
it comes to the russia conflict uh and
i didn't exactly expect that to happen
in part because so many of these regimes
are kind of mixed authoritarian regimes
that seem to draw a lot from putinism
and yet you know now in poland there are
just mass reserves of weapons that are
going to be shipped to ukraine it's hard
for me to believe that that with all the
military intellectual capital that i
assume exists in russia
that they wouldn't have seen this coming
you know like oh they're all disunified
now's the perfect time to attack now is
the perfect time to give everyone an
excuse to unify against some external
quote-unquote threat right like we've
have you seen any sci-fi movies like
that's always what [ __ ] happens
everyone's fighting and then an alien
invades and everyone comes together to
repel the invaders and then magically a
better world is born afterwards
so his very big mistake was
doing anything while everyone was bored
as [ __ ]
well i mean i think the problem is and
again this goes back to kind of like
ascribing a causal connection or
ascribing a psychological motive
like it's hard because
you know like a lot of arguments assume
a kind of rational actor they assume
that putin is a rational actor and
obviously that's that's not a good
assumption to make so it's just hard to
know
what you can really do is try to be like
okay well what might be his like
perception of like reasons to invade and
obviously that's one account but i mean
you know i can't actually think of a
good idea we know the answer and we're
about to give it to you listener
big promises big pause big trouble as
good hegelians we do know what causes
conflict in the world
and it is the movement of history
so
we know there you go everyone else was
surprised yes this the cause is history
in case you didn't know everyone else
was surprised when this happened but
we knew
we've looked at
the philosophical underpinnings of
eurasian nationalism as told by uh get
ready for this pagan occultist slash
traditionalist slash orthodox christian
fascist
slash stalinist who didn't think hitler
was so bad you know bad
but not so bad and he's got a definitely
a rasputin
aesthetic going on and supposedly also
having putin's ear to a degree i have no
idea maybe maybe you guys know but he
wrote a book claiming
that it was russia's historical right
nay
duty
to annex ukraine in the service of a new
russian empire which is the only thing
that can hold back the tide of
moral and cultural decadence emanating
around the globe from the west and from
the us
usa and this book is what like uh 20
years old already uh he's written a lot
but the book isn't wasn't fourth
political theory written a little bit
more recently like 2011. 2009 and it was
published in english uh in 2012 and then
there's a new edition that came out
recently
no i mean 1997 is when he released his i
think his foundations of geopolitics is
how it's usually um translated uh text
and even at that point you're starting
to talk a bit about pan eurasianism uh
and the kind of anti-american or
anti-liberal bloc it just wasn't given
the kind of philosophical gloss that you
find in the fourth political theory
we're talking about alexander dugan here
the russians oh you spoiled it you
spoiled everyone's favorite fascist
sandwich
we're talking about honestly this is the
scariest
philosopher that he's like evil
i mean heidegger is already pretty evil
but this is like dark heidegger dark
timeline heidegger heidegger is like
darth vader um you know he's you know he
he wants deep down inside there's a good
goodness to him but this guy this is
like
this is emperor palpatine
his his his aerodition his learning is
is quite astonishing though he does cite
a wide range of theorists he like he
knows his [ __ ] but yeah i mean clearly
he's he's playing this sort of role or
been ascribed this role as a kind of
state philosopher
uh and he you know it's it's hard to
separate what
parts of his ideas he's borrowing which
seem
somewhat cogent
and and which ones are being fitted into
this sort of role he's playing and you
know you can imagine he can't if he if
he says the wrong thing you know he
could run afoul of the kremlin and
get booted out so sort of for over 20
years though he's been saying we need to
unify the russian speaking peoples of
ukraine and you know ukraine's not even
a real country anyway so we should just
take it back
yeah there's like a unified eurasian
culture is kind of like the the term he
likes to use but dugan is interesting
because i may have i've probably spoken
about this on the podcast before but you
know i first learned and i've been kind
of fascinated
on kind of on the side with dugan
because in my department of political
science at the university of toronto
there was like a famous oh yeah you had
that controversy yeah yeah go ahead you
made a controversy with this student
michael millerman who's now fairly like
well known on twitter in certain kind of
like conservative intellectual circles
whatever
um
and so he was writing his dissertation
which i think it was a very interesting
topic and he ended up publishing it uh
as a book
um with a questionable press but anyway
let's leave that aside for now but the
topic i think was very interesting the
word is a fascist press
yeah yeah but he was doing basically
like i think what is on the surface very
valuable work which is just like
comparing or like reading heidegger as a
political thinker
and basically doing a comparative
analysis of four readings of heidegger
uh one being leo strauss another being
dereda another being richard rorty and
then the fourth being dugan um so his
his his dissertation was on that and
then what ended up happening is
his uh committee
at the time kind of found out who dugan
was after they were initially working
with him realized dugan was kind of
crazy and had like very reactionary
you know well we'll talk about whether
or not he's a fascist but you know
seemingly fascistic views and they all
ended up essentially resigning from his
committee
and he struggled uh to finish his phd
and he actually ironically the person
who ended up supervising him
uh and didn't resign from his committee
is actually like like a post-colonial
like deridian far left uh political
theorist who is like whatever this guy
this guy's smart like he's he's doing
good work like
i want to help him on on to finish his
phd she just from kind of like an
intellectual values level
didn't agree with what was happening uh
in the department there's actually a
national post story written about this
so all of this is like public knowledge
it's not really like inside gossip
must have been a bunch of liberals on
his committee yeah the council it was a
bunch of libertarians cancelled on his
council culture but there's the tolerant
left for you and he said and he said
that he actually made that comment he's
like all the people who resigned from my
committee were kind of like either
straussian center like leftist leo
strauss types or like center left
kind of like you know yeah i mean they
were like liberals basically different
different which all plays perfectly into
these narratives that you get from dugan
and from peterson and from trump you get
these narratives about cancellation and
centrist and left liberals being
moralistic and i mean you just they just
play right [ __ ] into that don't they
they put their foot in their mouths like
don't know design on moral principles
that's so stupid
i i do want to
yeah and and the one who supervised him
a ruth marshall so this is again public
knowledge on the in the article
she basically like said exactly that you
know that that it's it's it's playing
into their hands and and this is like a
dumb thing
i'm gonna supervise them all right we're
gonna get to uh matt here to actually
introduce this character to us in a
second but the last uh the last thing
about the intro that i wanted to bring
up was
how weirdly close
some of his language is to phenon
fenon who is a
pan-africanist post-colonial
revolutionary theorist like very
far-left communist
and then dugan on this
i don't even i don't even know if this
fits the right left axis very neatly but
this we need to resist
the imperial center we need to
resist imperial domination from the
western eurasianism we need to establish
a personal identity for for
russo
slavic extended extended peoples land we
need to resist yeah americanism yeah you
get a
nice mirror a nice parallel i think i
made that comment when we were doing
earphone episode that a lot of his
arguments could fit into i don't know if
i said dugan by name but i think i made
the comment that it could fit into some
conservative kind of reasoning and he
loves pragmatism too i was just watching
a thing like he loves american
pragmatism he says oh america you're
losing your true spirit capitulating to
these globalist liberals you need to get
back to your pragmatist roots and read
emerson and read james oh my god it's
weird anyway sorry go go on matt we'll
get to matt now yeah so if you ever
wanted an episode where matt talks a lot
this is that because he's the expert on
this
yeah you actually read all of the fourth
political theory and
and uh pills was saying maybe it doesn't
fit on the left right spectrum but maybe
you could also explain you know because
the title of the book is kind of
speaking to that whole complication of
the spectrum after you talk about who he
is be like what are these four things
and you should look at also our
listeners should look at this wikipedia
page because he is variously
a
gnostic satanist occultist
but also a traditionalist christian
and it's it's very confusing he was he
was uh
yeah part of a satanist group that
studied the waffen
the the ss waffen divisions true occult
studies so
it's a fun wikipedia page but anyway
matt who is this guy
what does he say
and uh what's the fourth political how
afraid are you who is his daddy and what
does he do
yeah how afraid should we be
intellectually less afraid than some
people might actually think uh although
geopolitically any situation where we
have 9000 nuclear weapons pointed at the
rest of the world is cause for concern
all right which isn't five thousand west
what
five thousand five thousand thank you i
looked it up recently that makes me feel
much better right yes and while we're
pedantically correcting each other it's
uh nuclear not nuclear little george
bush's in there yeah nuclear clear it
can only kill everybody on the planet
three times over that's pretty weak i
think like ten but anyway okay yeah no i
mean it's it's definitely a lot better
now i will i'll get to know that my
ashes will still persist somewhere right
but you know it won't be pulverized
right down to atoms love the bomb baby
yeah yeah but anyway i want to say that
i was first introduced to dugan actually
probably around 2018 um particularly
because of his work in geopolitics where
in 1997 he wrote a book foundations of
geopolitics
which argued kind of in the same vein as
samuel huntington who's also referenced
several times in the fourth political
theory uh that
history was moving uh because there is
such a thing as history right he didn't
think was over there was a kind of clash
of these big global blocks right uh in
this case you know he argued for a kind
of pan-eurasian uh block that would
confront the hegemony of western liberal
or neoconservative at the time hegemony
and when he says pan eurasian how much
of asia is included in that
well that's really not something that he
settles political or theoretically in
part because he says it has to be sorted
out politically right um but he makes
the argument that again as you said a
lot of the russian-speaking countries or
russian-aligned countries could be
probably part of this pan-eurasian bloc
including all the over older soviet
states sometimes he flirts with the idea
that there could be kind of suno [ __ ]
russian alliance right so between china
and russia that would obviously be
pretty powerful but it really matter it
depends a lot on contingent
circumstances that can't be settled uh
immediately right and you're fair enough
right
but you know the thing about the book is
that it really is a work on geopolitics
uh in the sense that it's actually
pretty grounded right in the sense that
it talks about power politics the recent
history that kind of stuff but it
doesn't really have a kind of
theoretical or ideological
oomph to it at least not compared to
what you see in the fourth political
theory which is really intended to kind
of give a philosophical gloss
to a lot of his ideas and i do want to
say that
he does actually confront the problems
uh with the left-right spectrum pretty
head-on
and he draws inspiration from at least
two of the three great modern political
theories as it calls them but there
should be no kind of doubt about it that
he himself situates himself on the
political right uh he describes himself
as a conservative a traditionalist
any number of different terms you know
that are used somewhat interchangeably
in the translation that i read and it's
worth just quickly chiming in that
traditionalism also means something more
specific we don't have to get into that
but i want to refer people to matt and
i's interview with benjamin title bomb
which we did a little while ago where he
explored
capital t traditionalism so listeners
should check that out if they're curious
yeah exactly it's like a specific thing
isn't it yeah yeah it is yeah and so you
know um
he refers to some of these terms
interchangeably uh there's a reason for
that because you know the chapters are
kind of um
not intended to be holistically oriented
in this book right they kind of stand on
their own and so there's sometimes
different terminologies and different
references used in each one
but you know what kind of makes his
conservative or traditionalism
conservatism or traditionalism
interesting is its willingness to engage
seriously with certain kinds of radical
left ideas but it's worth noting only
those radical left ideas that he thinks
are amenable to a critique of liberalism
uh and more permissive sides of
modernity right so so in his mind
liberal liberalism and neoliberalism and
the expansion of
you know valueless americanism
this is the great evil that's wrapping
itself around the world is that is that
fair to say well can we call it an evil
that itself is a question in the book so
look i just want to say first off i
really don't like this book not just
because i don't agree with it
politically but also because i don't
think it's really all that good
intellectually
one of the reasons i'm not sure that
it's very good intellectually is it's
kind of gleefully inconsistent
in its approach to things
now there is a reason for that and i'll
explain it but look let's just make it
clear right uh one of the kind of
consistent themes that comes through in
the book is that there are three major
modern political theories uh two of
which dugan respects one of which he
does not right uh the two that he
respects are broadly speaking leftism
right radical leftism in particular
marxist tradition uh or the communist
tradition however you want to call it
again used interchangeably the second uh
is the fascist tradition right now there
are different flavors of fascism that
some of which he finds more appealing
than others and i also want to point out
that he's very clear that he's not a
racist uh fascist right or he's not
attracted to racist versions of fascism
not hashtag not all fascists
yeah i mean you might think that's just
absurd to say but you know there's an
argument for it we can talk about it but
the one there is there there is a
legitimate argument for that i mean i
had to teach in an ideologies class
about mussolini and stuff and like
fascism and
i think that it's true like we often
because nazism is so dominates our
imagination of fascism i think we do
actually forget um that intellectually
fascism has no necessary connection to
race and who's this italian fascist that
he always uh recites
most consistently right and ebola made
exactly this argument that the problem
with fascism this is putting it really
briefly right uh is that it's not
radical enough or not radically uh
critical of an ever more radical like uh
theory right yeah exactly right yeah you
still find you find these chains on the
right also because of all this kind of
point is that nazism and eventually
italian fascism because you're right
victor there was a transition right as
nazism became more influential uh kind
of gave into this crude biologism right
where it basically ceded to modernity to
the idea that we should be rationalistic
and scientific in our approach to things
like the nation right uh and we should
discriminate on people against people on
the basis of their biological race right
because some are scientifically inferior
and some are scientifically superior
ebola wants to have nothing to do with
that right uh because it's too crude too
materialistic too modern right and
digging sympathetic with that right
i believe dugan called the modern
sciences
demonic yeah weird thing for a satanist
to say but yeah and he also i mean
that's exactly right so he's so called
satanist
so-called
you're satanism's weak boy
traditionally i think fascism he just
sees it as too modern right as matt was
saying it's too much of a about related
to modern rationality organizing society
rationally right in a unified way i
think i think one of the one of the
broad outlines to point to in his theory
is that is that yes liberalism fascism
and communism are the three ways that
modernity has specifically produced
right and he wants his fourth way to be
a kind of amalgam
of what's best in post-modernism which
he really respects
and
his kind of pre-modern traditionalism
that's so his fourth way is
another one of these sort of now kind of
common currency actually in critical
theory ways of moving beyond modernity
altogether of which sort of
post-modern post-modernity since the 70s
has really just been an extension of
modern modernity and a radicalization of
what modernity already created he wants
to move
past that so that's that's another one
of the broad strokes right these three
fascism communism liberalism they're of
a peace they're different but they all
come from the same sort of time period
beginning with the discovery of the
americas
slavery
eurocentrism all these sorts of
historical things that have built up
since the 16th century right and a cart
right but it's worth noting again that
he's willing to have a lot of good
things to say about elements of fascism
and elements of
this is probably called communism or
marxism right yeah but again uh the
fascist element is definitely the main
one in the fourth political theory the
one that he clearly is most sympathetic
to the elements of marxism that he's
willing to be interested in
generally relate back to the critique of
capitalism right uh and critiques of uh
american and u.s imperialism especially
an enemy of my enemy is yeah his
approach but i mean the one that he is
stridently opposed to at all cost right
that we will never ever offer a single
session to uh is liberalism right uh
that's the main target uh that he's
arguing against over the course of the
book again pretty inconsistently i
should say uh because the reason he
justifies this animosity isn't really um
clear well it's not unclear it's never
consistently uh argued for but i mean
that's the main enemy uh and he sees
this as being embodied in the united
states uh which is kind of the ultimate
liberal country what are the main
reasons that he that he hates liberalism
i know you said they're inconsistent but
well the reason is that the big
inconsistency in the book is this right
on the one hand he broadly endorses a
kind of relativistic approach to
morality which in and of itself is
interesting uh because he acknowledges
like he's a smart guy right that this is
an insight he gains from post-modern
theorists like foucault for example
right uh that we can't make an argument
for universal truth claims whether about
how the world operates or the way that
it should operate right
and based on this he makes an argument
that you see a lot of conservative
authors make right that uh morality to
the extent that we say it exists uh is
communal right uh it can be defined at
the national level at the civilizational
level maybe at the imperial level right
but it only applies in its respective
region right now one thing that you
might immediately come back at is to say
well then why doesn't liberalism just
apply in its respective region right if
these western countries want to be
liberal then that's their morality okay
uh and at some points in the book he
actually does acknowledge that there's
more kind of passive moments right where
he says if the west wants to do
liberalism and accept lgbtq people
and accept trans identities that's fine
does he talk about that those things
specifically oh yeah it falls under the
label of posthumanism right amongst
other things right and we can talk about
that but at other points he makes it
very clear that he's not going to be as
acquiescent that there needs to be kind
of a militant pushback against
liberalism by russia or by pan
eurasianism and he also encourages
conservative groups in the united states
to try to do the same right uh and
that's when he uses very morally loaded
language that doesn't sound relativistic
at all right characterizing liberalism
as evil decayed demonic you know you
picture he does so he does the the thing
that all post-modern theorists do which
is actually be crypto normativists yeah
i know that that's exactly
he he is anti-universalist
that's his thing right that's my
understanding his position against
liberalism and he does sort of
speak favorably of some older forms of
liberalism but he is against liberal
universality so universal things like
human rights is is one of the things he
opposes because he sees that
as something that is imposed on other
people and he doesn't like that he's
down for this sort of what you're saying
like cultural self-determination kind of
idea that he picks up from
post-modernists but he also cites uh
friend boas and anthropologists and
cultural relativism as well as an idea
he likes to build on but he's
specifically against
universal universalizing claims another
thing he picks up from he picks up a lot
of these things from post-modernist kind
of strategies right this is i this is
identity politics or or standpoint
epistemology for fascists
yeah i mean you're absolutely right that
that a lot of the book makes that kind
of argument right but then that leads
you into the problem of course which is
that
if morality is just a matter of your
perspective and if it's localized to
certain regions then it's very difficult
for you to launch a compelling criticism
of something like liberalism for reasons
that he understands right then you just
say well if they want to do liberalism
in the united states and western europe
that's fine right that's what they can
do there
and what's also problematic of course is
if it's the case that people in these
regions believe in the universality of
their doctrines then that's just a kind
of cultural perspective that they take
that their doctrines apply everywhere
it's kind of hard to criticize that
right so at other points in the book he
does appear uh to use victor's terms to
crypto-normativist or sometimes even
moralistic language or even crypto well
crypto universalistic too because he's
if he's making these moral claims they
have to apply like it's it sounds like
you're saying he makes them
in a way that they sound like objective
universal claims yeah exactly he's
saying they belong to the eurasian
people they're he's he's arguing for
morality specifically it's not crypto
universalist
yeah yeah from their standpoint uh it's
ugly it's evil it's bad etcetera right
except clear um how those terms are
meant to be understood if they're just
uh
they just apply from that particular
standpoint and it's also worth noting
yeah but this i just want to i just want
to clarify this point because i want to
make sure that i'm getting the kind of
inconsistency that you're saying in the
book clear because you're saying at some
points he's like okay from our
perspective
these things are demonic
but then so and then he wants to say you
know if the west wants to be liberal
they can be liberal but then at other
points the book it's you're saying it
sounds like he's making claims from his
standpoint that are condemning the west
yeah but but but in a way that sounds
like it's actually more of an objective
universal claim because otherwise he
would just be like fine we don't agree
with that but the left can do or the the
west can do what they want to do
universalism and normativity are not the
same thing you can make local normative
claims you can't make a local universal
claim that doesn't make sense but you
can make a normative claim that has a
limited
geographical or historical application
whereas you can't make a universal claim
that does that because that's what a
universal is it's a predicate that
applies to everything in the collection
you're talking about yeah
the problem is that's clearly not the
case in this book right where throughout
he does make
claims that are very much loaded uh with
universalistic language that aren't
normative claims about the ugliness the
evil uh the tyranny the danger uh of
western liberalism and why it needs to
be confronted both in russia and
elsewhere right
and it's also worth noting that he goes
even further than a lot of at least the
early post-modern theorists will do by
claiming that what we need is a return
to theology as well right so there's a
kind of theological dimension to this
where sometimes they'll even describe
this as a kind of religious
confrontation between the spiritually
robust uh
god-fearing russians right
mysticism
uh or decadence west right and
it's very hard to kind of make an
argument for the religious veracity of
your point of view without appealing to
some kind of
universalism which he does all our
universalistic language so you're saying
he's so you're saying if i'm hearing you
correctly that he's like
a conservative but he also draws on a
lot of post-modernism i wonder if
anyone's written
on that i don't think i've talked that's
a new phrase to me what what i like
about this though is like
i've heard of that
yeah just going today what i really
liked about this book yeah i mean i
agree is while i really was reading this
i don't i won't lie and say that i
didn't have a few moments of vindication
right but what was interesting to me
about this is what i was describing was
a kind of unconscious phenomena right
that concerns have been stamped by
features of post-modernity whether they
knew it or not and they were agitating
uh for these kind of politics and
positions in a pomo away right whereas
what dugan is doing because dugan is a
very smart guy right i'm not denying
that is he's making this kind of
self-conscious right where he's saying
yeah i've read darity for co deliz is a
very frequent reference in the text and
he says i'm doing that but for these
kind of conservative causes
yeah he's like the he's the flip side of
someone like gramsci who's arguing for
cultural global uh capitalist hegemony
and this is our form of resistance to it
is you know everything that the leftists
tried but they got they got killed for
it and then now we have that
right-wing mirror of that
yeah that was my point about that weird
amalgam of post-modern ideas and and
kind of traditionalism theological
values mysticism traditional you know
it's a weird kind of
kind of uh melting pot of ideas he's got
going before before we talk too much
about these specific ideas um
because we brought it brought up the
putin bit matt can you explain a little
bit the connection like how this guy
you're saying is evil and dangerous but
maybe not so dangerous so what do we
have to uh look forward to from this guy
is he
someone that
putin like draws on directly or is he
kind of a useful
a useful clown for the for the state
what is his connection to the ukrainian
situation
and actually can i just say can i
suggest matt that
maybe one of the most obvious ways into
this is just to read
uh one of those facebook posts that
dugan made in response to the to russia
invading ukraine yeah yeah absolutely i
mean he's on facebook and he
has some juicy commentary on there about
the the recent situation so feel free to
look at that if you want but it in front
of me if you want me to read one of them
yeah please i don't have facebook
okay so uh this is i think like on the
day of the invasion and he says this is
not a war with ukraine this is a
confrontation with globalism as a whole
planetary phenomena confrontation at all
levels geopolitical and ideological
russia rejects everything in globalism
mono polarity atlanticism on the other
hand and liberalism anti-tradition
technocracy great reset in one word
word in another it is clear that all
european leaders are part of the
atlantic liberal elite and we we went to
war with her hence is their normal
response um russia is now being excluded
from the globalist network
she has no choice anymore either to
build her world or to disappear russia
has taken a course to build its world
its civilization and now the first step
is being taken but in the face of
globalism only a large space a continent
state a civilizational state can be
sovereign no country will last a
complete blackout for long russia is now
creating a field of global global
resistance her victory will be the
victory of all alternative forces both
the right and the left and all nations
as always we begin the most difficult
and dangerous processes but when we win
we all share that's the way it's meant
to be we are now creating the premise
for true
polypolarism uh and those uh who are
ready to kill us now will be the first
to use our feet tomorrow i almost always
write when uh what then comes true this
too will come to pass
that's that's seductive
victor now now you put me on the prophet
you put me on the fascist pipeline
thanks
well this is why i've never liked
post-modernism because i think it opens
the door to this opens the door yeah so
we should just close our eyes and
believe liberal modernity is the best
we've ever had or ever will have it
yeah and i want to know one of the
things that i was reminded of when i was
reading dugan's book is a point terry
eagleton made and his book the illusions
of post-modernism uh where he says a lot
of these people on the left will invoke
things like particularity
anti-universalism uh anti-liberalism
forget that these actually had their
root in conservative thinking people
like edmund burke uh or joseph dumas
well actually can i yeah before you go
on with that though i do i do just on
the quote i was wondering if
maybe i think it's important to define
this whole talk about polarity pull uh
polarism
so okay so look i mean this is something
that's consistently uh a major theme in
his work right uh because again dugan is
interdisciplinary let's just put it that
way so he's not just political theorist
he really is concerned about uh
everything from the movies people watch
uh to practical geopolitics you could
almost see him uh as a kind of dark
slavojija that way if you want also
right there's nothing that he won't talk
about right uh but the basic idea is
that strategically and culturally uh
there is a kind of
problem uh with the world order as has
existed since 1989 or 1992 right which
is that we live in a unipolar world uh
one where there is one superpower or
hyperpower as it puts it in the book the
united states and it gets to essentially
set the agenda for the rest of the world
uh and while there can be some kind of
deviations
from u.s
soft or light imperialism in countries
like iran or north korea they don't
really have an awful lot of force and
the countries that try to stand outside
of the u.s imperial order
are considered bad rogue states the axis
of evil whatever you want to call it
that so he's making an argument that
strategically what you need is an
alignment of culturally uh and
politically illiberal countries that can
serve as a kind of bloc that's
sufficiently powerful to confront uh us
and broadly speaking liberal or western
hegemony right uh and
is it always very sensitive uh to the
vast differences between different
flavors of illiberalism right the
reality is i would say that
chinese socialism with or the china's
socialism chinese characteristics or
third way socialism or authoritarianism
whatever you want to call it right is
very different from what you see with
putinism right
but again the argument is that if all
these people align and you get enough of
them we'll be able to confront uh the
west and provide a resource for people
who want to confront uh its decadence
within those countries so this so this
polarity then is another is another way
as a kind of geopolitical way of
describing
what philosophically he wants
as you said inconsistently but he wants
there to be like room for different
value systems uh to exist in the world
so multi whereas right now he feels like
the liberal view is dominating with with
america and and the west
and it's so in that sense it's unipolar
geopolitically and culturally and i
think he is so you're saying that so the
geopolitical way of describing that is
multi-polarity right so he wants to
build where there are several legitimate
kind of
value systems that coexist in the world
yeah and he draws on a number of
different authors from across the
political spectrum to make this argument
right i mean again one of them is samuel
huntington uh who's critical of
huntington was famous for making this
class of civilization's argument in 1997
right uh where he argues that look
different civilizational blocks could
theoretically serve uh as a kind of
counterweight to the hegemony of the
west but he also does draw on some
leftist criticisms uh of united american
hegemony as well particularly in the
marxist tradition you know by arguing
that uh illiberalism uh can be conflated
with
anti-capitalism and then maybe you could
align some anti-capitalist states uh
into this block as well right it's a
fairly open-ended kind of project right
uh the only thing you need for
membership if you want to put it this
way really crudely is to be illiberal
right uh if you look at the lgbtq
lifestyle and something in you thinks
that's wrong and it should be put a stop
to congratulations uh you might be a
country that can be in dugan's illiberal
blog so
again i wanted to re reiterate my
question is putin listening to this guy
or is he a mouthpiece for an actual
project or is he just an esoteric
uh eccentric publishing weird books and
and meeting with steve bannon
no i mean
i like victor i don't want to be
unicausal right there can be this
temptation on the part of philosophers
this is a podcast we don't want nuance
we want the hot tapes
yeah i'm going to give it so look i mean
there's this kind of temptation that
people like heidegger won't get fall
into and dugan is the same way which is
to say ultimately the ideas are what's
determinative of the world uh so dugan
will sit there and write his book in
1997 and whether the people at the top
actually know it sooner or later they'll
be influenced ideas and they'll
implement them right well he he does
have some sort of an official position
in the in the kremlin does he not
he does
some titles
and he's also maybe the or was he still
at moscow state university or whatever
i'm not sure i think
yeah so look i mean
again i'm trying not to be unicosal in
the sense of saying that dugan basically
determined i thought we said that nuance
wasn't allowed here okay but let me let
me just let me just quickly say though
that i think
it's hard to i guess the answer the
direct answer i think to pills this
question is that like it's hard to know
how much influence dugan actually has on
putin i don't know i haven't read all
the literature on it but my
understanding is like
is some people think that yeah they talk
all the time and he believes that other
people think that
that putin just sees this guy dugan
talking about eurasianism which kind of
roughly maps on to like putin's fixation
with wanting to have more influence
geopolitically to be relevant right i
think ultimately putin sees how russia
used to be so relevant with the ussr and
now they're really they were kind of
falling into irrelevance so i think he
sees this philosopher talking about
stuff and he's like oh yeah like this is
an argument for us to be relevant again
so so but i don't know i mean i watched
i actually watched re-watched the putin
interviews from 2016. you know oliver
stone interviewed putin for like four
hours uh over several different kinds of
different days
and uh because i was just fascinated to
kind of like get a refresher on what
putin's like and my impression from that
is like i don't know how philosophically
sophisticated putin is i don't really
think he necessarily is yeah
my hunch would be that he would not
understand
dugan's books but he has a geopolitical
interest in and some vague notion that
russia needs to be relevant again so
maybe that's just like um
you know uh kind of
they have uh interests that coincide
enough so that they can be like uh to
kind of move like pointing in the same
direction
but i doubt like putin actually like
understands the philosophy yeah that's
what i was going to say right again
trying to avoid being unicosal i don't
think that dugan influenced putin to be
the way that he is right uh this is just
me speculating right because i'm not
privy to what's going on in the kremlin
uh at least not yet right um
i think though that dugan is a
convenient ideological mouthpiece uh for
a lot of putin's ideas who can provide a
kind of theoretical justification yeah
uh that's appealing to a lot of people
not just in russia but outside of russia
people like millerman right uh and you
can sometimes see echoes of duken's
arguments in the kind of rhetoric that
putin will use because a very consistent
point that comes through in all of his
work uh is this idea that the west is
hypocritical right because on the one
hand uh it makes an argument for
universal human rights respecting
national sovereignty uh being sensitive
to cultural difference right while on
the other hand trying to impose this
kind of monological liberalism uh acro
and capitalism across the globe right uh
and often doing so by imperial means uh
and he doesn't actually believe that
yeah no that means there's no doubt that
he's neither new nor controversial is
that idea yeah no he's absolutely right
about that but what's unique about this
uh is again you'll often see putin
bringing up this fact to accuse the west
of hypocrisy whenever somebody points
out that russia is now engaging in these
kind of imperialistic projects and
trying to export its national ideology
um through the invasion of ukraine
through invasions in georgia uh through
kind of interfering uh with them and and
and installing puppet puppet governments
yeah or in belarus yeah exactly right uh
and you know he says you know basically
you're doing it we're doing the same
thing except we're doing it better
because you know we're doing it in favor
of the right ideology and people in
russia love that right because he's seen
as sticking up for the west now as an
argument it's bunk right because saying
you did it so now we get to do it also
uh is the kind of morality or the ethos
that children take right uh but it does
have some political credibility to it uh
so it wouldn't surprise me again if
maybe he skims over dukin's works picks
up on these kinds of arguments and then
articulates them and he does talk about
you do hear putin say stuff about like
multi-polarity and and uni polarity i
mean that i mean that that idea as as as
matt mentioned you know with like samuel
huntington and stuff i mean i think that
that language has been around in kind of
like geopolitical
geopolitics for a while so so that's not
you know unique to dugan but dugan gives
it some philosophical
uh uh um kind of underpinnings but matt
i was curious
i think one thing that might be
important and since we've talked we've
covered heidegger before on the podcast
i think it would be interesting to to
ask like what role does heidegger play
for dugan
he plays a foundational role for him
although again that's only in certain
chapters okay so the best way to
describe this book would be
imagine that
imagine that delusion qatari did an
awful lot of crack cocaine moved to
russia and decided to become fascists
and rewrite a thousand plateaus right
you get something that looked a little
bit like the fourth political theory
because it's not a book uh or holistic
book in the sense that we would
understand it right where you kind of
start with an introduction you move
through the various chapters and subject
matters then you reach conclusion right
each chapter can kind of stand on its
own and he makes theoretical
observations about a wide variety of
different traditions some of which he
likes and some of which he doesn't and
doesn't make it too much of an effort of
trying to say how this all fits together
right and by the way this isn't me
speculating he says that's what he's
going to do right that he's engaging in
this kind of playful pomo reading
of a lot of these figures so when it
comes to somebody like heidegger he's
obviously on the right side of history
uh you know pun intended right
because he has this argument for the
authenticity of a collective da sign
right
that he makes in the 1930s right this
idea that the nation state can express
itself authentically if it has the right
leaders and if it breaks from the
decadence and inauthenticity of
modernity and obviously he's extremely
uh attracted to this and he calls it a
kind of revolutionary conservatism right
uh a conservatism that doesn't just want
to kind of hold back modernity or
compromise with modernity uh but wants
to overthrow it wholesale in the name of
a kind of national identity now
obviously he points out that
heidegger also didn't go far enough
because he kind of lapsed into
supporting the nazi party with his crude
biological racism uh so bad for him
right so you could see dugan's project
at least in the chapters where he's
talking about it as an attempt to kind
of do this 1930s heidegger project right
you know to get it right this time and
he appeals to the concept of dazain to
kind of ground his sort of moral
relativism right because he wants to say
that there are different different
designs right a rootedness well this is
this is the uh the most nazi heidegger
got was probably the speech the
directorship speech and there he talks
very much about uh yeah you know the
ground the rootedness connection to the
earth the volk and uh yeah that sounds
like something being reproduced here in
another language obviously no absolutely
and just like in that speech you see
heidegger sometimes gesture to elements
of liberalism without ever calling it
that by talking about the importance of
freedom so too dc duke and talk a lot
about freedom but real freedom or
authentic freedom in this text right uh
the freedom of the nation-state uh to
express it's true design uh but it's
interesting that he also sometimes has a
bit more of a nietzschean flavor to some
of his work as well because he says that
the problem is that liberalism has
always focused on equal freedom for all
by which he means kind of equal
permissiveness for all right uh the
right of everybody to choose what kind
of ice cream flavor they want to eat or
to [ __ ] whoever they want right which by
the way i endorse um some apparently the
horniest philosopher of the musical
that's that person in our chat said
anyway um but you know dugan says that
the kind of freedom that's not allowed
by liberalism uh is the freedom of
superior people or people with more
imagination or creativity to engage in
these kind of grand projects of
political or self-overcoming whether
individually or collectively
and
this kind of freedom can only happen if
you have something approximating an
authoritarian society where people can
use others as play for these kind of
grandiose projects now he never quite
explains
what he means by this or how
authoritarian we can get
but it's clear that there's a kind of
echo of nichianism that you find in
heidegger and now and dugan
with this fixation on greatness or at
least spectacular project and unlike
nietzsche and heidegger he endorses uh
i think specifically orthodox
christianity
but not because you should believe
anything about christianity it's because
you need some sort of social glue
to bring the volk or the people together
to make them have this coherent project
yeah i mean again i'm not nobody's going
to read this book and accuse him of an
excess of consistency because you might
think if we're going to be epistemic
skeptics uh not just about normative
universals but about
knowledge claims generally then how do
we know about god but the argument is a
functional one right that theology has
served russia well uh or a kind of
russian orthodoxy has served russia well
as a glue that's not only held society
together uh which is again a kind of
functional argument but more importantly
it's oriented russians towards these
kind of spiritually great uh or
invigorating projects right rather than
just focusing on satisfying material
needs uh they focused on these grand
spiritual uh and religious enterprises
right and he's attracted to that uh
and you know he's not the only person on
the far right to sometimes vacillate
between a kind of niching attraction to
atheistic great projects uh and a kind
of admiration of spiritual or religious
great projects right the one thing
that's constant
through all these vacillations is that
whether you're an atheist nichian uh or
kind of uh or heideggerian or a kind of
russian spiritualist you're illiberal
right you do not buy into liberalism and
you buy into something that's
more appealing uh and more
deep and deep than liberalism
there it is
yeah so i mean
like i said intellectually the book is
maybe this is gonna make me sound a lot
like an analytical philosopher and like
a liberal theorist it's not very good
right it's all over the place and
there's really no effort to try to paper
over
the intense contradictions uh within it
but i think dugan would say that the
demand that he do so uh is itself
reflective of
a kind of liberal mentality that was
actually what i was going to say next is
why are you harping so much on
consistency as if consistent ideas are
the ones that win
yeah i know that's exactly what he'd say
right that i'm not interested in things
like consistency or rationality uh at
least in the liberal sense of the world
i'm interested in these kind of creative
intuitive dynamic projects that will
help thinking break out uh of its boxes
uh and lead people down the course
also showing showing you why you think
your consistent world view your
consistent liberal world view is
actually very inconsistent kind of
point i guess too sure
so i'm curious does it make the two
co-hosts who are a little bit more
sympathetic to post-modernism are you
guys finding this just super appealing
are you guys going to become i mean i'm
finding this dangerously
dangerously seductive yeah you are
aren't you i can't speak for eric of
course but dugan is reacting to the same
thing
we do more so than you libs and that is
the pervasive attitude on the part of
mostly everyone who has a stake in this
system and you know the stakeholders who
control politicians through donations
who who can afford to pay the salaries
of mouthpieces in the mainstream media
and the attitude of them
liberals generally is an unabashed
smugness about the totality
of their fantasies about the world
yeah okay we invaded iraq and that was
bad but it was just a miscalculation and
just a miscalculation but it doesn't
really matter anyway because iraq was
not free
so iraqis of course are outside of
history miscalculation on our part and
this comes out from liberals not just
philosophically but the way this is
intermixed with
ever-expanding capitalist interests that
they make history their morality is real
morality and will never make anything
new we'll never let you have something
new so you stupid little leftists and
you stupid little protesters and you
stupid little delizians why are you even
trying
history if it's not over as some of them
say but if history is not over then
it's our business
history is liberal business
literally and anyone outside of that
iran uh china russia we are going to
sanction you and make the lives of
ordinary people a living hell just
unbearable because again they don't get
a stake in our story we don't get a
state they don't get a stake in the
grand narrative
so i'm sympathetic to leftism insofar as
it is opposed to that smugness that this
thing is
rotten with a pretty face
and that happens to be the same thing
that dugan argues for so the rest of the
shade is pretty scary admittedly but i
have
no
difficulty no trouble understanding the
appeal of this line of thinking at all i
do i guess the best i think the best
analogy
for this is probably um
i'll get to it it's kind of a weird
thing to see somebody who draws on all
the same thinkers that i respect
and does something different it's like i
want to use all these thinkers
post-modernists i like what he reads
right he talks about duluz and foucault
and derrida and he talks about
pragmatists like purse and james and
dewey and he and he approves of them as
well and it like the best analogy i can
think of is like we're working with the
same material but whereas i want to
build
a nuclear power plant he wants to build
a nuclear weapons facility and they're
very similar things but they have very
different functions in the end now don't
they one of them is to help people and
the other one is to [ __ ] people up and
that's just what i feel like they're
both made of the same [ __ ] they both
look the same but they're very [ __ ]
different and that's the best analogy i
can think of because it's jarring to see
somebody who lines up like he said his
favorite post-modern philosopher is
bruno latoya
he really likes that book
we have never been modern right because
it fits right in with this whole thing
right it's like anti-modern that's the
basic position he has he's an
anti-modernist and he sees
fascism liberalism communism all coming
from the modern period so he likes this
book we have never been modern where
latour argues that modernity or what
latour calls the modern settlement was
this sort of
like resolution between scientists
represented by boyle robert boyle and
philosophers represented by hobbes and
they said you can have your section and
we'll call that nature and you
politicians you can have your
ontological division of the world and
we'll call that culture and then the
modernist settlement was born and here
we are today
with this sort of dualistic world view
mind body subject object and and he and
he brings up these sorts of and i think
they're very good arguments they're very
very keyed into what modernity is all
about but again he wants to build a
weapons facility and i would rather
build something that's a little more
useful than that so so what accounts for
that difference right um so like doesn't
that mean that you need under you need
to actually just like take a leap and
make a normative claim uh for like why
you prefer
the power plant over the weapons
facility
yeah well i don't i'm not i'm not
opposed to normativity right you know
like
but he's trying to do a gotcha no
normativity
is not something that's precluded by
post-modernism what post-modernism is
interested in is how did we get this
normativity where does the normativity
get built how over time do we get to
normative claims first calls aesthetics
ethics and philosophy the normative
sciences that's what they're designed to
do whenever you hold a belief about
something all beliefs are normative
right a belief is what you would do if
this situation would arise that is by
definition normative humans and all
animals
contain normativity and generality
within them right it's not a big [ __ ]
deal unless you're kind of like a
radical particularist
brought up on a diet of only dairy diet
and then then maybe i don't know but but
do you think that there's a way in which
like dugan is somehow deciding
by using kind of his
like you know anti-modern anti-kind of
like like logo-centric rationalistic
view to then say well because i can
clear the space of all these like
imposing scientistic kind of claims like
normative claims that are like
pretending to be based on reason
then now from that standpoint you can be
like yeah actually we do have a russian
culture i'm choosing to say russian
culture where we can exclude gay people
exclude trans people exclude exclude
exclude and build what we want it's like
17 year old boys to die
yeah and then so how do you so then
so i guess it's like so what protects us
then it's like we need something uh to
protect us from that if we're gonna use
all these same philosophers to say no
these philosophers actually
uh are are about uh you know there
should be some some principle to lead us
to inclusion or something but then
that's the thing right are we going to
go with the noble lie in that case then
is that the normative claim you're
looking for we need an oral we need a
noble lie which may be completely false
like all humans are equal
whether or not that's true or false
that's the no that's the noble thing
probably a lie that we're gonna go with
right and then you get back into this
whole problem of again platonism which
dugan likes he loves platonists right
he's neoplatonism yeah he's into that
[ __ ] too so you're right back in dugan's
arena again and you gotta then now
normative claim yourself out again with
a different lie it's like he's lying
about one thing i want to lie about
something different just become liberals
it's it's great
it is
just believing in something like
universal human rights doesn't make
universal human rights exist
on a justified philosophical ground
that's why you need the lie no well here
what i want to say lies are true what i
want to say
is that i think the thinker who is most
consistent on this basis and somebody
that he relies on quite a bit in the
book not as much as some other people is
somebody like to lose right because
when you read daredevil's work or you
read the work of somebody like michelle
fico
they're pretty insistent that their work
is intended to be interpreted for
radical purposes radical left purposes
uh
or in daredevil's case kind of soft
radical left purposes delusion was the
only one i could think of who was honest
enough end of qatari a thousand plateaus
to say look we're not sitting there
saying be rhizomatic right because
rhizomatic thinking might be more
democratic it might be more inclusive it
might be more hyper martin to use
dugan's term uh but it can also mean
microfascism emerging right or
neo-fascism uh or traditionalism of that
sort right uh so
and there is no barrier that we can put
up to those kind of things on the basis
of our way of thinking about it and
dugan in some senses seems to have taken
up that challenge to say fine i am going
to do a kind of rhizomatic
traditionalism uh from a russian
standpoint and
am i surprised by that no uh do i think
it's interesting yes do i think it needs
to be confronted uh and destroyed at
every single level where possible yes i
also think that because i think the
world that he's arguing before is a
horrifying one
and that doesn't mean that liberalism is
without tremendous flaws uh modernity is
without tremendous flaws
but as both a liberal and a socialist uh
i think that we need to have a say a big
no to this way of thinking about things
i think what makes us different too is
i'm not a canadian
and victor victor i know you were saying
this kind of tongue-in-cheek but saying
well just become a liberal and reassert
those values no the correct response to
this would be
you have to overcome him aesthetically
which means you have to be more
interesting than dugan so [ __ ]
consistency just be more interesting be
more i actually work too yeah i mean
that's part of the danger right because
you know every every state has its
ideology its philosophy its state
philosophers kind of thing every every
state has that and you know in
combination with some kind of political
agenda or geopolitical strategy right
the spearhead of those strategies is
always going to be an ideological front
that's that's how it works right you got
to get the you got to get the
justification out there ahead of the
front lines and then hopefully you can
neutralize some of the opposition get
certain people on your side every state
does this this is just a reality this is
a real politic reality that happens and
he's doing it for russia and what i
guess what makes us different is that i
am not claiming that canada is some
fallen empire that needs to be restored
and i'm gonna do it with charles sanders
person felix guterree that's not my
claim that's that's sort of dugan's
claim about russia right so it's it kind
of puts his ideas in line with a certain
kind of political agenda so as as
as you know as well as he presents his
ideas as as appealing as they seem and
the nice
friendly veneer he puts on his his
interviews where he doesn't like i mean
it's just like watching jordan peterson
right it's like it's like i don't
disagree with everything he says but
it's sort of the spirit in which it's
presented that puts me off a little bit
and that's the same thing with dugan
here
he's not saying anything that's like
wrong or controversial i mean when you
get down into the sort of yeah and like
looking for the analytic points where he
contradicts himself okay there you go
you could desire some more detail but in
the end you know it's the proximity of
his ideas to a certain geopolitical
strategy that probably makes them the
most dangerous
yeah yeah i mean i mean i think i think
right now what we're seeing too is i was
gonna say like bringing it back to the
perspective of ukraine
you know i think
that if that quote if if dugan the
duganites think that what putin is doing
right now is like fulfilling that
i mean it kind of seems to me like it's
backfiring you know because like if this
sort of like western idea identity was
the thing that needs to be overcome it's
like it might have been better strategy
just sit back and and watch the west
keep internally quibbling over like
nonsense like mask mandates and like let
it kind of like decay from its own
decadence but instead you know the best
thing you can do for like a cultural
like block or whatever is to give it an
enemy
um and i think that's really what putin
just did
yeah i i agree all kinds of differences
need believers right and the more
believers the more self-fulfilling the
prophecy
the west than the more people who
believe that's going to happen is more
likely it is to happen yeah and you i i
really it's too bad that um you know uh
we might have to wrap up soon because i
i you know i spent actually quite a bit
of time reading through uh michael
millerman's paper that he was because
michael millerman was tweeting when all
this was happening he was tweeting about
dugan subsequently ended up deleting
them i don't know maybe because he got
uh i think he pulls himself into
controversial discourse
um but i read so he i read one of his
papers that was posted on his
academia.edu page that he was posting
kind of being like if you want to know
what dugan's about like read this if you
want to understand right if you want to
understand the views
um
and i think like what what was
interesting about the paper that i
wanted to quickly touch on is just
the way that millerman is kind of trying
to defend dugan from
these accusations that he's a fascist
um or that um you know that that he's
and and what's interesting about the
paper is he describes dugan's view but
then
he ends up saying like basically he's
making these arguments on what to me
seem like technicalities
to be like see he's not technically a
fascist because he wants to go beyond
fascism and i'm just like
how is this an argument defending duke
and it's just like
so like he does three things right so he
says um you know because fascism is
actually a modernist view he can't be
fascist so calling him a fascist is
stupid i'm like so like what matters is
like what dugan is actually advocating
for which is terrifying it's not whether
he sounds like a duck walks like a duck
yeah whether he's technically a fascist
or not and people know that in the past
i've kind of argued about how stupid it
is how like the term fascism can be just
used pejoratively kind of like for
anti-intellectual
uh means and like i'm sympathetic to
that like it's true like it makes more
sense to see what dugan is actually
saying than just call him a fascist but
when you see what he's actually saying
it's [ __ ] crazy okay and then and
then the other thing that he does um
which is kind of interesting is he says
you know oh like people say that he
wants a bipolar world and it's like he
actually wants a multi-polar world and
it's like okay again he's like the whole
paper is like fixated on little
technicalities but then my favorite one
was he's like oh a lot of people say
that he he's trying to recapture some
lost unity you know it's like a
retrograde grade conservatism
conservative view but it's like no that
assumes a unidirectional account of time
but really dugan
has a uh what does he say has a
synchronic view of time so it's actually
like cyclical
yeah um so
if you understand
so if you understood that it's actually
cyclical time then you would see that
it's his
you're wrong to say that he's retrograde
because he wants to go beyond so it's
just like funny that he thinks that
these arguments over like the kind of
philosophical minutia
is somehow like a substantive defense
of dugan i mean maybe i mean he claims
this is really just a defense of like
reed dugan so you understand what he's
saying like that point i would agree
with like if you want to know what he's
saying you should read him or spend a
little bit like some time making an
effort to read them but it's just like
when he says oh he's misunderstood it's
like okay all you're showing me is like
a misunderstanding of these like little
philosophical points but i think what
people are actually interested in
substantively is like what are the
what's the way the world dugan wants
what is the way that dugan wants the
world to be
and do we find that normatively
appealing or not and yeah but isn't this
kind of like that's
kind of what matt is doing here a little
bit by exactly by saying that don't
worry don't worry everyone his arguments
are inconsistent
but the consistency we've decided is
something that doesn't matter because if
he has on his
backing up his ideas uh the russian army
say
then it doesn't matter whether they're
consistent or not that's fair what i'm
saying is that we shouldn't worry too
much about it from a purely intellectual
standpoint ideologically worries about
anything from a purely intellectual
standpoint
yeah i also want to say
ideologically what i think is terrifying
is that i can completely see why this
would be appealing i also want to say
that mickelman or millerman himself
seems to misinterpret dugan because he
didn't argue for a synchronic view or
even a cyclical view of time but
pluralistic view of time right there are
many different ways of understanding
time that are appropriate in many
different circumstances right but i mean
that's kind of pedantic and of itself
and i agree with what you said victor
sitting there and defending uh a fascist
or a neo-fascist by saying he's not for
race biologism and racial fascism and
racial chauvinism uh but for ethnic
chauvinism uh and ethnic
authoritarianism instead it's kind of
like well great i don't ease me uh when
i'm terrified to sleep at night well
he's also interested in in in fascism in
the non well if it in if it is fascism
it's a type that is non-rational right
because i mean i do take there is a
substantive point to be made to say that
like classical fascism
is still a kind of
rationalistic political theory right
because it's like about rationally
organizing the society along certain
kinds of like
you know collective goals with an
authoritarian organization at the top
and i think that he would be saying that
dugan is not doing that because he
opposes that kind of rationalistic
reasoning kind of irrationalist yeah
it's a kind of irrationalist uh wave of
with mysticism and all that stuff right
in that sense dugan is actually in some
ways less innovative uh than the
classical fascism and i mean that you
know with big scare quotes because he
kind of just wants to go back to the
good old days of conservative
authoritarianism when it comes to his
domestic approach to politics whereas
lisa fascist tried to innovate in their
own kind of warped and evil way when it
came to how to conceive the state and
what the objectives of the state are
going to be because one of the things
that dugan insincerely claims is that
he's interested in experimentalism
throughout course of life that he wants
each nation-state civilization empire to
be kind of an experiment uh and have its
own viewpoint have its own way of doing
things uh and that they shouldn't be
interfered with appealing to the old
american democratic experiment there
yeah except my argument would be that he
arbitrarily decides that they should
only apply at the nation-state or
civilization level but not to
individuals because of course john
stuart mill would make exactly the same
kind of argument that each life should
be conceived as an experiment
individualism is the best way to get the
most kind of pluralistic viewpoints out
there in the world and dugan says no we
should have homogeneity uh relative
homogeneity at the nation-state level
because it's each nation-state or
civilization that's supposed to
experiment not each individual because
that's decadent materialistic and a
symptom of decline and i also want to
point out that this kind of milsion
viewpoint is very much in line with what
marx and a genuine socialist tradition
argued uh in the third volume of das
capital mark says that the beauty of a
socialist society will be that for the
first time in human history the
amplification of human powers will be an
end in itself not amplification for the
purposes of production but for its own
sake right uh and that's what i would
like to see the application of
everyone's individual human powers not
the amplification of the powers of a
brutal authoritarian nation state that's
invading its neighbor and
won't even allow uh the citizens of that
nation state to express their own design
uh by criticizing people like alex or
sorry like alexander dugan and vladimir
putin anyway dugan says the uh
individual is a social construct
facts [ __ ] yeah doesn't he explicitly
um
kind of prioritize
i think he he explicitly prioritizes the
collective over the individual
yeah that's his sort of chosen level of
analysis except it's it is really chosen
right he just arbitrarily says at one
point uh individualism is a social
construct which is true right you can
talk about the invention of the notion
of individualism from the 16th century
onward
except he says we will buy into any
number of different social contracts the
nation-state level the civilizational
level but i'm not going to buy into
individualism because of reasons right
and it's kind of like too liberal
yeah like
what an argument
he's really owning the libs
yeah you know it's i kind of want to
touch on something you said earlier
pills about uh because yeah i mean it
was tongue-in-cheek when i said
just become a liberal um but i do think
there's a
but but i think it's interesting what
you said uh well because to be more
interesting uh like that should be the
goal uh you know i feel i guess what i
would say about that is
uh you know i think what i'm seeing
there is kind of like your artistic bias
coming through right you know i think
when it comes to political
like
organizing a society um politically i
don't know if people in their day-to-day
life are really looking for things to be
maximally interesting
i think they're looking for some
consistency so that they get on can get
on with their life and like do the
things that matter to them as opposed to
you know them being surrounded by all
this interesting stuff eruptions going
on all around them you know i don't know
if most people want that
yeah i mean isn't it like the whole
obsession with dugan from for somebody
outside of russia would be like a
product of modern technology
communications and globalism right
because how else would you hear about
this obscure philosopher from the other
end of the world unless you had this
global network in the first place to get
that kind of information to you
and yeah you're right mo
people are concerned with consistency in
their everyday lives and reliability and
those sorts of things so to become
obsessed with this sort of thing if
you're not like a professional scholar
or academic or political scientist to
even pay attention to these sorts of
things is is already a kind of
i don't know a strange thing that seems
to go against exactly what dugan is
saying he's like hey let's like let's
not be globalists but you know pay
attention to what i'm saying me this
person on the other side of the planet
who you'd only hear about because of
modern technology and social media it's
he
just kind of leans on things that are
outside the text i know i shouldn't say
that there is an outside of the text but
there is one and he leans on them
heavily that sort of thing the globalism
that he denounces he also leans pretty
heavily on conspiracy theories about
globalist elites and stuff like that and
he
like owns that pretty much too
but i mean
it's
there's a there's a certain lack of of
maybe
trying to
evaluate the purposes of of his project
and what he's doing and you know the
ideas are appealing yeah and like
whatever but like what's the end game
what's the end game for it all it's a
kind of
russian expansionism countering a nato
expansionism neither of which are a good
thing
but
you know two wrongs don't make a right
i mean i prefer nato expansionism
i mean you know i get i get the point
about it being like imperialistic in its
own way but of course you prefer that to
you for you because you're sitting in
nato yeah yeah of course
about lining up nuclear weapons on the
borders of countries that don't do
business with us or that we do things we
don't like like that's not a great thing
either i mean i agree with you i mean
that seems like a step so
i think like
i think
i i think i want to resist like i think
there is some kind of like
effort on some people's part to make
kind of like a moral equivalence between
like what i mean i'm not saying that
you're doing that between like what like
a putinism is kind of trying to do
versus
like nato i mean nato in itself so
there's i think there's it's important
to distinguish between like nato as a
treaty as a defensive treaty versus
american imperialism stuff that they did
during the 20th century like invading
and and installing puppet regimes that
were like uh pro capitals
that's separate
well okay well i mean whatever recently
i'm just look yeah recently they left
they left afghanistan nato left
afghanistan like
six months ago i'm just saying there's a
difference between like nato as a
defensive treaty
um versus like the stuff that america
has done kind of clandestinely well
you'll be
nominally defensive i didn't say
nominally i did
oh i mean it's nominally defensive i
mean in the sense that there's not going
to be like
any first strike coming from from nato
sure okay they won't shoot missiles
first but they will
rig your elections with well-funded
pro-western candidates and then embargo
the [ __ ] out of you if you have the
audacity to elect anyone hostile to
those western capital interests
i mean even look at the difference with
what america and and and the british did
in world war two right they like they
pushed the nazis back
and then they gave the countries back to
the population what did the what did the
ussr do they pushed in they kept
everything that they invaded i mean so
there's just like two different ways of
approaching
uh
approaching that
that i'm like one to me seems clearly
morally better than the other god damn
you gotta give me some of your what
you're drinking a billion dollars of of
marshall plan money was given to the cia
which were transferred to local law
enforcement in europe to just kill
leftists
i mean
i'm not saying i'm not saying that that
you know there's not things that are
morally questionable i just don't think
they're the same i think it's worth
making the distinction between like what
are the two tendencies of like whatever
the former ussr and how they've handled
and their their form of imperialism
versus like i don't know the nato
alliance which is kind of like
uh you know a pseudo voluntary like
capitalistic i mean obviously stuff that
america did was not voluntary right that
they were like you know influencing
clandestinely um
states but there's i just think there's
there's a there's a difference there
yeah i mean there's there's definitely
a middle course to be
run between all of this sort of you know
everything with liberalism is rainbows
and sunshine and everything with
capitalism is is [ __ ] like atrocious
and and disgusting for people like i
mean there's
there's certainly a middle course to be
run between those two things and i don't
think the answer to you know the world
being in a really shitty state rampant
inequality exploitation and all that
stuff i don't think the answer is to
just like jump ship onto some nut job
russian mystics philosophy and start
doing that sort of thing i don't think
the answer is that
but i mean i mean the fact that it's
appealing shows you that there's a lot
of discontent out there with the current
status quo
that's true i mean i don't find it
appealing at all but maybe some people
do
maybe you you and pills do a little bit
at least there's there's some mild
appeal
yeah well he deals with he deals with
ideas that i'm very familiar with but
it's it's
it's they they come in a form and a
packaging that i'm somewhat unfamiliar
with
i guess you could say like i don't i
can't just divine everything dugan's
about because he knows the same
philosophers that i do i have to i still
have to read him and figure out what
he's all about how he's constructing his
arguments and
what they're doing and then and then
obviously the geopolitical context that
they're sort of blowing up in right now
that's all important stuff that add to
the texts too right not the text isn't
just this isolated thing you read and
then you get these ideas from it they're
embedded in a context that's what i'm
trying to say
but it's
it's difficult to it's difficult to
evaluate just on the basis of his ideas
alone
because
a lot of them aren't really that new to
be honest and i think you know all these
stories about nato this and i mean yeah
for sure some people you can interpret
nato expansion as a form of aggression
but i also think it's just as reasonable
to it to to believe
that without nato a lot of these baltic
states would would all have kind of
putinous
puppet governments
i think that like nato is a big
disincentive from putin doing his funny
business where he you know assassinates
people uh poisons people and installs
um puppet government so i can understand
the incentive of a baltic country or a
balkan country to be like i want to be
part of nato because then putin can't
[ __ ] with us
yeah and you can you can't
i mean this is part of the problem with
the conversation about it too is like
you said earlier jumping to causal
explanations and i would add two
justifications right like nato
expansionism is obviously an important
aspect of
the history of setting up the conditions
for this situation but then people want
to jump and say that's a cause or that's
a justification of the situation that's
that's not good historian work then
you're you're leaving the realm of
explanation and going into personal
opinion which is fine but you know it's
not you just got to be aware that it's
probably incorrect and to more much more
complicated than that
which is a shitty answer but that's
[ __ ] life right if it ain't
complicated then it's probably [ __ ]
there's no reason to think i guess also
that argument is often premised on oh
like if nato hadn't expanded then like
russia would just what be keeping to
itself and not [ __ ] with any of its
countries like that clearly doesn't seem
right to me like like if nato wasn't
around there's there's there it's just
it seems at least as reasonable to
assume
that they would be just as incentivized
if not more incentivized to [ __ ] with
their former soviet countries well the
liberal these liberal philosophers like
the
the ones in the room here they're just
going to defend the nato status quo
whereas
whereas dugan is going to defend the
russian status quo but in the end your
opinions don't really make a difference
to the situation in any case you're just
providing justification for one side or
for the other and i mean it's also
important to look at you know like
countries from the global south and why
they're so hesitant to get involved in
the situation or or like openly condemn
the russian invasion and
it's not because they don't they don't
think it's wrong i mean there is the
cases where they're allies of russia
like venezuela they don't so they don't
want to say anything
to antagonize their friends but there's
also the important point where a lot of
them feel that
that
the u.s led nato and the eu and the
united nations they all created this
situation it's their fault not
intentionally but they created this
situation and that they should take some
response
ability for it right and that they don't
want to get involved because they see
that this is part of some kind of
u.s agenda
in order to you know save face after the
disastrous withdrawal from afghanistan
or some other sort of thing right
america perceiving itself
especially after trump as no longer
being you know the world power there's
still kind of the world power but you
know not as much as they used to be and
this and they some people see in this
situation just the kind of u.s led
way of trying to gain credibility again
and they don't really want to be a part
of that especially if they have a
history with the u.s
[ __ ] with them sen and extracting
their resources giving them nothing back
kind of thing
and i mean again it's a complicated
situation but it's not it's not it's
never been
unipolar or bipolar in the first place
that should be the title of a book we
write we have never been bipolar or
something like that right
that would be a better title for a new
latourian book because i think this
whole unipolar bipolar
multipolar that's really what he wants
kind of ridiculous and it's you know you
could read gutturi get the same argument
out of them is this left right
bipolarity is [ __ ] we need more
centers of political thought we need
more than just a spectrum that has two
ends to it you know like we need we need
up down left and right and diagonals as
well right we can't have and we do have
that but they're all organized around
liberal or conservative
and then sometimes you add the other
axes of power or truth but that doesn't
solve anything but you get that same
like like i said dugan's ideas
are not new
they're quite some of them are quite
familiar but the packaging and the sort
of way they're being presented is a lot
different i'd say well the way they're
being justified right yes
it's new it's like uh
how they're being deployed yeah well i
don't know if there's any other
philosopher who
because most people who use the
philosophers he likes are obviously
arguing for some form of like socialism
or anarchism or something something
obviously more on the left spectrum so
i don't know if there's any other
philosophers who use the same and and
come up with the decidedly
right wing
you know kind of like authoritarian
um
sort of like picture of the world that
they want well we haven't brought this
up yet but the thing that makes him
philosophically the same as those people
that you're you're talking about um
adorno comes to mind but this uh it's
anti-hegelian
really that's what saying we need
multi-polar or
a pluralist time is saying is we want uh
a non-hegelian history
and in in fukiyaman fashion the hegelian
history is one of
eternal expansion of the neoliberal
nation state and embodied in this case
by nato nato country yeah i think i
think what he does a lot better than
jordan peterson is he he
elaborates this eclectic base of ideas
and areas of thinking and then he kind
of relates them directly and extensively
to politics
which which you know jordan peterson is
really dog [ __ ] at doing i was saying
we were complaining a few weeks ago
about how boring jordan peterson is and
how shitty his interpretations are so
here's
the interesting good at it
dugan's just good at it that's all i
also think that peter i also like to be
you know i think i think peterson is is
a modernist he's he's for the western
project
i think he's a globalist i mean
self-described classical liberal he's a
he's a liberal like i don't actually
think like yes he has a conservative
spin but i think he's very much within
the the mind frame of like the west is
doing something important that needs to
be spread to the rest of the world like
i think he is a bit of a proselytizer
for a kind of individualist
uh kind of like suck kind of like neat
like
christian-esque
sort of like the private individual
the private individual so ultimately he
is like part of the modern
western project
and um
and i think so so in that sense he's
quite quite divergent
yeah i mean i no i think i think the you
know david harvey gives a good
intimation of what happened you know you
know the in that i mentioned this
already that comparison between the
treaty of versailles and the humiliation
of germany is setting the stage for
world war ii
and then i guess you know after world
war ii the lesson was learned and the
penalties were not harsh like like they
were after world war one
that generation of politicians seems to
have died out and not passed their
knowledge on and then after the fall of
the soviet union
russia was humiliated excluded treated
as a basket case the ruble went into
hyperinflation they were trading in
vodka at one point which is where all
the jokes come from
and
again now we have this situation again
where this humiliated trampled on nation
is again coming back
for a revenge with a more distorted and
even more distorted kind of ideology
than the one that first was taken down
and so we have this parallel again
between you know humiliation in the one
hand the humiliation on the other hand
and and humiliation is a dangerous
political tool it is very [ __ ]
dangerous and we and again
the same thing has happened to china
right they've been humiliated colonized
by britain colonized by japan they have
a deep memory these all these
humiliations are going to come back and
[ __ ] us over
and there's
you know there's not much that we can do
about it because the seeds were laid by
a previous generation of idiot
politicians who didn't who didn't give a
[ __ ] about what the next generation was
going to have to deal with and now we're
dealing with it i think that's an
interesting line of argument that harvey
brings up anyway
hmm
yeah that's interesting all right well
we've been going for a while are there
any
quick final thoughts you know what how
are you you all you guys feeling about
the potential of nuclear uh catastrophe
uh another chernobyl
the cold war is back yeah another anyway
large tracts of europe going to be uh
uninhabitable are those no rad bases
still up like or is toronto is toronto
within range of an icbm coming over the
north pole
uh so canada is not part of the missile
shield the united states does have a
missile shield which they they could
potentially use
um but none of that actually matters
because russia has these hypersonic
icbms that the current technology of
america's missile shield can do nothing
about so if they wanted to they could
bomb any target in
america
the missiles will go into space at an
incredible speed and every it'll all be
over in 30 minutes they would actually
get they would actually get to the
united states from russia in less than
five minutes that's how fast these nukes
are we've all forgot but we do still
live under mad right mutually assured
destruction there's no that doesn't stop
i'd have to you know maybe i'm a little
over exaggerating that but my
understanding is
no no they're like they're they're like
20 times the speed of sound these these
hypersonic icbms i mean it won't if if
you know one side launches the nukes the
other side launches the nukes they're
they're all targeted already so they'll
just be everything will be destroyed
that's not that's not a way forward for
anybody the only the only real thing you
could possibly worry about is if putin
sees him he's losing he might just be
like all right well i'm taking you all
down with me
but other than that i mean it's not a
way forward until toronto is nuked
stay tuned every friday we put something
out
and uh why don't we wrap up on that
happy note
on that on that optimism yeah and
actually i will tell you right now so uh
the so the fastest icbm uh goes
24 000 kilometers per hour
yeah i mean at this so that would take
more than an hour to get here
why are we 24 000 uh kilometers from
russia
probably i would i would put it at
around that
what's the circumference of the earth
like all of our maps because of that all
of our map projections distort it so
it's difficult to tell because they're
they're six thousand six thousand
kilometers all of our maps are very uh
atlanto-centric so it would take two
hours or three no it wouldn't
no it would take way less six thousand
it's twenty four thousand kilometers an
hour it'd be here in like 15 minutes
oh twenty four thousand i was thinking
twenty twenty four hundred okay okay
okay no twenty four thousand kilometers
so it'll be here oh that's a lot i was
thinking twenty four hundred damn that's
a
quick
barely enough time to put your coat and
shoes on and get out the door
no point no point in doing it
yeah so what are you gonna do when when
the missile launches victor be just
lib you should have been liberal
yeah
we should we should do an episode on uh
dr strangelove
that'd be a fun one yeah
how to love it how to stop worrying
i definitely am not worried i actually
find it more fascinating than worrying
to be honest which maybe it means i'm
sick but i find it just
it's just so much more interesting than
the stupid like truckers or like vaccine
protests i'm like finally something
interesting is happening no war but the
culture war
yeah i'm tired of being annoyed by
things that don't actually matter
yeah exactly
yeah all right well that's a good note
to end on it all right
cheers guys
cheers listeners
goodbye
later y'all
[Music]